the daily wire Promenade right wing
Media company will stream all of its
shows on Twitter starting May 30th
aiming to expand its audience according
to daily wire's CEO co-ceo Jeremy boring
the overwhelming amount of positive
feedback from our advertisers and
audience signals tremendous opportunity
the move comes as conservative media
personalities increasingly turn to
Twitter seen at is it it is the platform
that refuses to engage in content
censorship based on politics former Fox
News host tuck across and announced
bringing his program to Twitter and
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis plans to
formally announce obviously we know that
the daily wire multimedia content
featuring fire breathing conservative
commentary covers politics pop culture
entertainment Matt Walsh apparently who
on his YouTube channel was saying he was
making around a hundred thousand dollars
a month and he had something that he put
about the trans or the drag shows he was
going against it he got a strike and he
says you know what if this is what you
guys are doing we're moving away from it
so what are your thoughts about daily
wire choosing to take all of their
talents big names Shapiro Peterson
Candace Owens Matt Walsh I got a lot of
good guys there to Twitter he huge
massive it look it cannot be overstated
the importance of this move right now
and DW was ahead of the curve with a lot
of this stuff because they started doing
you know their full video podcast and
you want to talk about daily wire for me
is somebody that is sort of you know
looking to venture into the video
podcast space now I look at a Candace
Owens podcast it's like this is what a
video podcast should look like this is
what it should be this person is on
point she looks fantastic every day it's
culturally relevant it is all of these
different things so when you take these
things and put them on Twitter as the
full video element what this is saying
is that Twitter and Elon musk's moves
remember the new CEO of Twitter Linda
yaccarino what did she do before that
she was head of AD sales at NBC
Universal they are turning Twitter into
a hub for video content and they have
not even started to talk about how
they're going to be monetizing that yet
outside of subscriptions and so this is
what I say and I was saying in one of
you guys before you came to the podcast
foreign on Twitter it is not going to be
enough to just say in order to get
a following at this point nowadays like
maybe you could have before uh maybe a
little bit right now yeah you can just
hop on Twitter and start saying things
this is going to be become a platform
for high quality video content for
people that know how to articulate
themselves on camera for people that
know how to put that video content out
there and we talk about the decline of
cable news and we talk about the fact
that Matt Walsh cannot say
um factual things about quote unquote
transgender youth on YouTube without
getting completely demonetized on
YouTube Twitter is the new platform so
they're ahead of the curve they were
ahead of the curve two years ago when
they started creating and producing
these these podcasts I I did Candace's
podcast a couple of times
um back when they were doing sort of the
like the panel format and then they kind
of switched it to where it's just her
and I think that that format works a lot
better I think it's a lot stronger but I
think there's a size seismic move Tom
I think and I just looked up something
here I want to grab a couple dates I
think the move of her going to Twitter
is as big as when Sheryl Sandberg went
to Facebook Cheryl Sandberg is not
credited with making
um Facebook
um ad business she's credited with
making Facebook profitable it was
unprofitable until she got there and she
put the ad business and the associated
monetization programs in place and she
did so without diving in and changing
what was on Facebook the product guys
were some excuse me the product
individuals were responsible for that it
led by Zuck himself and I think that
that's what's going on here I think that
she's looked at it this is how they're
going to monetize it and that you know
Elon Musk knows what he wants to do with
the product he knows what he's adding to
the product and I think he's been pretty
sensible about it so I I think this is
as big as Cheryl Sandberg going to
Facebook in 2008
she made the company profitable in short
order and then they put her on the board
of directors in 2012. well I'll let me
just give kudos to you because this
bleeds right into the pre to the
previous story which is speaking of meta
Facebook Twitter everything they were
talking about Linda yaccarino and Cheryl
Sandberg the story from Fox Business is
reports of Instagram making Twitter
competitor prompts comment from Linda
yaccarino you've said you've been very
critical of Facebook where basically all
they do is just copy what their
competitors doing or by their competitor
and they just make something different
or or improve upon it and that's
essentially what Instagram they're like
holy elon's on to something Linda
yaccarino the new CEOs onto something
we're just going to follow in their
footsteps which basically bleeds into
the previous story cable news is dying
everything's going on to digital media
these days everything's going on too
YouTube Facebook meta it's like the
writings on the wall and and Elon Musk
is essentially leading the charger it's
been there let me make a point about
Facebook I think that a lot of people
face Facebook is seen as dodgy and old
and irrelevant whatever so I've got
about uh closing up 500 000 followers on
Facebook I do videos on Facebook every
single day the ad Revenue that you can
make as an individual solo Creator from
Facebook videos people have no idea all
right people have no idea and the reason
that I'm so excited about Twitter as a
Creator because if I could be making
those Facebook numbers as myself me
personally as a Creator if I've been
making those numbers on Twitter game on
without risk without risk without risk
without risking yes that's a good point
because there are certain things that I
cannot say on Facebook there are certain
topics that I cannot go into on Facebook
but it's it's a huge deal
Linda your Carino game on everything we
need to know about Instagram's Twitter
clone due this summer I love that this
is great just game on I love that
competition yeah I love that answer she
gives right there so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign